[Música]
Rusia bombardea masivamente Ucrania las
fuerzas de Moscú lanzaron 81 misiles
contra
kievsan all VIP entre otras ciudades el
kremlin defiende que se trató de ataques
de precisión como respuesta a la
explosión en el puente de crimea se
cuentan hasta el momento 11 muertos y
decenas de heridos civiles
el coletazo del huracán Julia causó
desbordamientos de ríos y quebradas que
dejan al menos 25 muertos y más de 50
desaparecidos en las tejerías en
Venezuela el presidente Nicolás Maduro
decretó el estado de catástrofe natural
y ahora convertida en depresión tropical
Julia llegó a Guatemala tras devastar
otros países de Centroamérica Tenemos
reporte
recibieron el Nobel de economía 2022
según la academia sueca los premiados
ayudaron a comprender el papel de los
bancos en la economía de Mercado
particularmente durante las crisis
financieras
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
Rusia escaló su ofensiva sobre Ucrania
en horas de la mañana de Europa las
fuerzas de Moscú bombardearon
masivamente el territorio ucraniano de
norte a sur y de este a oeste el
ejército ruso disparó 81 misiles sobre
kiev
saporia jerson y miko Life entre otras
ciudades el kremlin defendió que los
bombardeos son una respuesta a la
explosión en el puente de crimea de este
sábado incidente del que Moscú acusa a
kiev Putin habló de ataques de precisión
sin embargo se cuentan al menos 11
muertos y decenas de heridos civiles
es revivir lo más crudo de la Guerra el
centro de kiev volvió a hacer este lunes
objetivo de un bombardeo un ataque que
se extendió por horas y que es el
primero contra la capital desde que el
kremlin desistió en su intento de tomar
esta ciudad nos despertamos esta mañana
con este saludo por parte de nuestros
vecinos usted verá esto aquí y por toda
la ciudad
al menos otras seis ciudades también han
reportado tales bombardeos desde el VIP
a lo bestia hasta harkiv en ipro y
saporiya en el este En esta última urbe
los bombardeos golpearon zonas
residenciales como esta para el
presidente de Ucrania el objetivo de
Moscú es claro pone para acompañados
quieren pánico y caos quieren destruir
nuestro sistema de energía no tienen
remedio el segundo objetivo son las
personas y esos objetivos fueron
elegidos especialmente para causar el
mayor daño posible el presidente
Vladimir Putin reconoció la ofensiva
aseguró que su respuesta a la explosión
que afectó este fin de semana a un entre
Rusia y la Península anexionada de
crimea se trata de un ataque que kiev no
ha reconocido pero sí lo celebro
según los datos forenses y de otros
expertos así como la información de
inteligencia muestra que la explosión
del 8 de octubre fue un ataque
terrorista un ataque que tiene como
objetivo destruir la infraestructura
civil crítica rusa
Moscú también celebró haber golpeado
todos los objetivos designados este
lunes además con la promesa de Putin de
una respuesta dura si continúan los
ataques desde Ucrania
y precisamente la comunidad
internacional condenó enseguida los
nuevos ataques rusos contra Ucrania el
secretario general de la otan James
calificó los bombardeos de horribles e
indiscriminados la comisión europea
habló de crímenes de guerra y el
presidente de Estados Unidos showbiden
dijo que son una muestra de la
brutalidad de Putin Marta Moya con las
reacciones Internacionales
La frágil sensación de normalidad en
múltiples ciudades ucranianas lejos de
los frentes de batalla terminó
repentinamente las condenas a los
últimos ataques contra la
infraestructura civil se han sucedido en
la Esfera europea una vez más Rusia ha
mostrado al mundo lo que representa es
el terror y la brutalidad la Unión
Europea dice que el ataque
indiscriminado a civiles equivale a un
crimen de guerra y algunos estados
miembros como Estonia y lituania
reiteran que no es el momento de dar
marcha atrás ante Rusia
cada vez que alguien piensa tenemos que
ayudar a Putin para salvarle la cara y
darle algo para que no haga una
estupidez eso solo le anima a seguir
avanzando porque se toma Este
apaciguamiento como un signo de
debilidad
lo que tenemos que hacer es proporcionar
defensa aérea desde al lado Aliado para
que los ucranianos puedan proteger sus
ciudades porque Rusia está
definitivamente escalando para dañar a
los civiles
el presidente francés Emmanuel macon
reafirmó el apoyo militar al gobierno
ucraniano y expresó su preocupación
los ataques deliberados de Rusia en todo
el territorio ucraniano y contra la
población civil es un cambio profundo en
la naturaleza de esta guerra el
presidente de Ucrania también mantuvo
conversaciones con el canciller alemán y
pidió una respuesta unida y dura se ha
programado una reunión virtual de
emergencia del g7 para el martes en la
que intervendrá bolodimirselenski
cambiamos ahora de información en del
Congreso anual del partido Nacional
escocés la ministra principal de Escocia
Nicolas tergien insistió en realizar un
segundo referendo de Independencia en
Escocia el año que viene a la espera del
fallo de la Corte Suprema que debes
decidir si acepta la votación la
mandataria señaló que los escoceses
apoyaron mayoritariamente partidos
independentistas en las elecciones
regionales del año pasado recordemos que
en 2014 los escoceses rechazaron en
referéndum independizarse del Reino
Unido con un 55% en contra de la
separación sin embargo Esther John
asegura que el brexit hizo cambiar a los
escoceses de opinión
Pero Westminster no tienes respeto eso
significa que este problema siempre
estuvo destinado a terminar en los
tribunales tarde o temprano mejor
temprano a mi modo de ver
si el tribunal decide como que lo haga
el 19 de octubre del próximo año habrá
un referéndum de independencia
vamos ahora con noticias de nuestra
región después de causar al menos tres
muertes en Honduras y de haber devastado
parte de Nicaragua Julia ahora
convertida en depresión tropical llegó a
Guatemala el fenómeno climático deja más
de 150.000 afectados en este país desde
donde nos reportó nuestro corresponsal
Andrés Suárez Jaramillo aquí en
Guatemala las lluvias no han cesado
Desde la madrugada De este lunes
territorio guatemalteco donde ya ingresó
la tormenta Julia degradada como
depresión tropical de acuerdo con el
Centro Nacional de Huracanes de los
Estados Unidos sin embargo Aunque este
fenómeno metereológico sus vientos ya
hayan descendido a 56 kilómetros por
hora el nivel de precipitaciones
preocupa porque ya hay decenas de
municipios incomunicados deslaves Ríos
inundados Por lo cual fue activado el
protocolo de evacuaciones están
canceladas las clases y el sistema de
atención a desastres está pendiente de
lo que pueda llegar a ocurrir este lunes
en cuanto al Salvador de donde proviene
la tormenta por la costa del Pacífico la
Policía Nacional de este país ha
anunciado la muerte de dos personas en
un municipio del oriente luego del
derrumbe de varios muros Y al parecer
una tercera estaría también sepultada
Honduras por su parte que es un país
centroamericano por donde no atravesó la
tormenta directamente ha sido ha
resultado uno de los más afectados
riadas intensas desbordamientos de ríos
provocaron el ahogamiento de tres
personas centenares de familias
afectadas y Se presume además Fuentes
extraoficiales dicen que una embarcación
de siete personas estaría desaparecida
y continuamos con información de la
depresión tropical Julia Porque el
coletazo de este fenómeno en Venezuela
causó al menos 25 muertos y 52
desaparecidos como consecuencia del
desbordamiento de ríos y quebradas la
vicepresidenta de Venezuela delsy
Rodríguez informó que el sábado por la
noche cayó tanta lluvia como la que se
puede precipitar en todo un mes el agua
arrastró troncos y escombros sobre la
comunidad de tejerías en el estado de
aragua a unos 70 kilómetros de la
capital Caracas los daños materiales
afectaron negocios viviendas tierras de
cultivo y bombas de agua potable
situación
y hay personas tapiadas ahí que no se
han encontrado necesitamos ayuda que por
favor que esa invoque a ayudar a sacar a
las personas que están enterradas porque
no sabemos si hay personas enterraten un
hermano desaparecido
se necesitamos apoyo Pues bien el dolor
del pueblo porque no nada más el mío el
dolor todo el pueblo que está aquí
metido
y este lunes es la fiesta Nacional de
Taiwán la presidenta atz hay un buen
advirtió que la isla nunca renunciará a
sus libertades y a su modelo democrático
una mirada la celebración de hoy a la
historia de Taiwán con el siguiente
informe
ante miles de taiwaneses los bailarines
ofrecieron un espectáculo tradicional y
la guardia de honor militar marchó
Taiwán celebró su fiesta nacional pero
el ambiente estuvo lejos de ser festivo
en medio de nuevas tensiones con China
la presidenta zaynwne advirtió a Beijing
el pueblo taiwanés y nuestros diversos
partidos políticos creen que debemos
defender nuestra soberanía nacional y
nuestro modo de vida libre y democrático
en este punto no dejamos espacio para el
compromiso los 24 millones de habitantes
de Taiwán viven bajo la constante
amenaza de Invasión por parte de China
considera La Isla como una provincia
Rebelde de la que tomará el control
tarde o temprano así sea por la fuerza
esta crisis se remonta a la guerra civil
china en 1949 los nacionalistas se
retiraron a Taiwán tras su derrota ante
los comunistas se instaló un nuevo
régimen que fue rápidamente defendido
por Estados Unidos este verano la visita
de Nancy pelosi presidenta de la cámara
de representantes de Estados Unidos
Crespo aún más las tensiones en
represalia China hizo volar misiles
sobre Taiwán en la ONU reiteró su
objetivo
la soberanía y la integridad territorial
de China nunca fueron rotas
china continental y Taiwán pertenecen a
una sola entidad esto nunca cambió
los chinos nunca hemos dejado de
esforzarnos por lograr la reunificación
a nivel internacional el estatus de
Taiwán sigue sin estar claro
solo 14 países la reconocen oficialmente
como estado y no está representada en la
ONU sin embargo Taiwán Disfruta de un
sistema democrático y se ha desarrollado
económicamente la industria taiwanesa
llegó a ser imprescindible teniendo la
mayor producción mundial de
semiconductores
continuamos en Asia según la agencia de
noticias de Corea del Norte los
recientes lanzamientos de misiles desde
pyongyang querían simular una lluvia de
armas nucleares tácticas contra Corea
del Sur una advertencia después de los
simulacros navales a gran escala de seúl
con su Aliado Washington recordemos que
en las últimas semanas el líder
norcoreano Kim Jong dirigió ejercicios
militares que implicaron el lanzamiento
de misiles balísticos con ojivas
nucleares simuladas y que algunos de los
lanzamientos cayeron también cerca de
Japón
y vender Nancy Douglas Diamond y Philips
recibieron el premio Nobel de economía
2022 por sus extensas investigaciones
sobre los bancos y las crisis
financieras La Academia sueca explicó
que los premiados sentaron las bases de
como el mundo gestiona ahora crisis
globales como la pandemia de Kobe 19 o
la gran recesión en 2008 Daniela Blandón
con los detalles
el mundo entero padeció los efectos de
una recesión financiera Global en 2008 y
2009 pero bembernanquila sufrió en carne
propia como presidente de la reserva
Federal entre 2006 y 2014 halló una
oportunidad de oro para aplicar sus
investigaciones previas sobre la
recesión mundial de 1930 que hoy lo
llevan a recibir el premio Nobel de
economía junto con Douglas Diamond Y
Felipe David
En un artículo de 1983 mostró con
análisis estadísticos y fuentes
históricas que las corridas bancarias
condujeron a quiebras y este fue el me
como que convirtió una recesión
relativamente ordinaria en la depresión
de los años 30 las corridas bancarias
son retiros masivos de dinero que llevan
al colapso de los bancos las
investigaciones de los laureados según
la academia sueca ayudaron a demostrar
como un rescate bancario en momentos de
crisis es clave para evitar colapsos
peores
en 2008 la gente entendió que parte de
lo que sucedió después de la quiebra de
liman Brothers fue que hubo pánico un
miedo al miedo en sí mismo y que la
respuesta para recuperar la confianza
fue importante para enfrentar esa crisis
los gobiernos de casi todo el mundo
rescataron a los bancos en 2008 lo que
generó un torrente de críticas debido a
que muchos consumidores sufrieron y
perdieron sus hogares mientras los
bancos se salvaban y sin duda lo que
pasó en el 2008 en Estados Unidos que
generaba una crisis financiera global
tuvo mucho que ver con comportamientos
poco prudentes de parte de los bancarios
y en algunos casos incluso delitos y eso
fue todo procesado el momento y también
generó un cambio en La regulación de
parte de la reserva Federal los tres
economistas recibirán lo equivalente a
885 mil dólares en Corona suecas por
haber logrado un galardón que ha llegado
a muchos estadounidenses y solo a dos
mujeres en la historia
sigan con nosotros
[Música]